Lucey fans can rejoice as everyone's
favorite devilish detective duo is back
in the City of Angels and this time
they've got demonic prophesies and Apple
loving ladies to deal with yippie ki
movie lovers I'm Jan and today we're
delving into the season 4 finale of
Lucifer on Netflix how the ending
relates back to previous seasons and
what it all means for the future of the
show we will of course be talking
spoilers so take care if you're not all
caught up when team Lucifer foil Father
Kinley's end the world prophecy and
banished dromos earnest fellow invading
demons back to hell in the season 4
finale Chloe thinks it's over but
Lucifer explains that now the demons
know he doesn't want to go back to the
underworld they'll eventually return to
earth maybe putting baby Charlie or
Chloe in danger Lucy breaks the news
that he has to go and be their king to
contain them it's a bittersweet moment
for Decker star fans because Chloe then
reveals that she loves Lucifer and he
confesses back to her first love was
never Eve was he who Clary his penis
this is a huge moment for both
characters especially Lucifer who not
only sacrifices a life he's built for
himself in LA but also the chance to be
with the person he truly loves and who's
grown to accept him for everything he is
in a selfless act
Lucifer gives it all up and returns to
Hell and as he does his white feather
angel wings return Lucifer had these
last in the season 3 finale when he used
them to protect Chloe bursts until that
moment in season 4 we've only seen him
with his much more devilish bat wings so
the return of Lucy's angel wings show
that he's finally overcome his
self-hatred and angst over whether Chloe
can accept him for who he is and he's
also finally come to accept himself and
stop battling his feelings for the
detective and there's an interesting
detail in this scene which circles back
to the penultimate episode of season 3
that in that scene like this one Lucifer
also called the detective by her real
name Chloe just before she kissed him
back then obviously Chloe thought that
Lucifer was just referring to himself as
the devil metaphorically but after she
discovered at the end of season 3 that
Lucifer was quite literally the devil
season 4 has been all about her coming
to terms with this knowledge
Chloe's struggle to fully accept
Lucifer's demonic side causes her to
fall out with Lucy which sets up the
introduction of Eve someone who already
accepts Lucifer for who he is and
someone who's also similar to him as she
abandoned heaven because she was bored
up there in much the same way that Lucy
was bored of Hell when he moved to LA
Eve is madly in love with Lucy but her
obsession ends up being unhealthy for
both of them when she encourages Lucifer
to return to his devilish punishing ways
the difference between her influence on
him and Chloe's is summed up perfectly
in this scene where the three of them go
to confront Ian and who's first Eve is
deliberately shown here as a devil like
figure on Lucifer's shoulder goading him
to lean into his darker side while Chloe
is the opposite an angel like figure on
his other shoulder reminding him that
those things are wrong Eve's portrayal
during much of the season is something
of a reversal of her traditional
biblical story where she was tempted by
a serpent to take fruit from the tree of
knowledge in the show when Eve returns
to earth she's the one tempting the
devil whereas back in the Garden of Eden
it was Lucy doing the tempting maybe
you've read about it in a little book
called the Bible the garden the snake
the apple the metaphors forever though
that's true the forbidden fruit was less
of an apple and more like a banana
because she was so wildly in love with
Lucifer it seemed like she was going to
be what set Kinley's prophecy in motion
and she did but in a different way than
perhaps expected as she killed Kinley
sending a message to a demon from Hell
to come back in his body so that she and
Lucifer could be together but eventually
by the end of the season Eve realizes
that she needs to truly discover who she
really is I've realized the way I've
been acting with Lucifer's the exact
same way of act
with Adam you know I keep trying to
change myself to be this person I think
they want me to be I would never ask you
to change Eve I like who you are I don't
even notice yet need to figure that out
I'm gonna need to do that on my own
it'll be interesting to see if Eve is
brought back into the show in a future
season she admitted to Mays that they
had a connection before she left so they
may still get together in the future
in the meantime Kenley did mention to
Eve that she could be the queen of Hell
by Lucifer's side and I wonder if
there's a slight chance that she might
end up visiting him there even taking
his place she did seem to love punishing
evildoers on earth so being in charge of
that in Hell could be a good fit though
it's possible she was just doing that as
she thought it was what Lucy wanted okay
what other ways could Lucifer get out of
Hell in season five for a clue let's
revisit what happened at the end of the
first season in that season finale
Lucifer was killed and went to hell
although it was only temporary as he
made a deal with his father God an exact
replay of that wouldn't be possible this
time as Lucifer needs a substitute ruler
to govern Hell in his place one
possibility might be that Lucy asks God
to send a different angel to keep
control over the underworld Lucifer and
amenadiel have several siblings some of
whom we've already met this Remi who
appeared this season when she tried to
take him Ana deals baby back to the
Silver City and there's Azrael aka the
angel of death who was introduced in the
season 3 bonus episode boo normal in
that episode
Azrael revealed that Lucifer was one of
her favorite brothers and that she'd
always meant to visit him in Hell after
his rebellion against God and I wonder
if this time she'll make good on that
and come to see him in season 5 an
alternative new character who could
resolve Lucifer's dilemma of being stuck
in hell is Lilith Adams first wife she
was named checked a couple of times this
season first by Eve Lilith tamed the
beasts of the night stupid perfect limit
and then by maze my mother Lilith let's
just say she wasn't mom with here now
what's interesting is that you've said
that Lilith tamed the beasts of the
night suggesting that if she were
introduced to the show
she could be a fearsome ruler who could
keep hells demons in check by the way if
you're a fan of chilling adventures of
Sabrina this will make sense to you
something that could be an intriguing
twist is that rather than Lucifer going
back to LA Chloe could instead become
his queen and how this isn't something I
could see working easily with all the
other supporting characters who'd still
be in LA so I could only see this
happening briefly until there was some
other resolution and talking of
supporting characters many of them also
went through crises this season like
Lucifer Chloe and Eve Mays discovered
she was becoming too dependent on
looking after Linder and her unborn
child after Linda told us she needed to
find her own partner maze did make that
connection with Eve although it wasn't
reciprocated entirely in a similar way
to how Lucifer was with Eve so perhaps
next season we'll see maze exploring
other potential partnerships as well as
continuing to kick ass the show's cast
are all absolutely wonderful and Amy
Garcia is just perfect as Ella this
season Ella's suffered a crisis of faith
after the death of Charlotte with both
her attitude and her t-shirts turning a
little darker and a l'heure and Dan also
shared a brief intimate moment which
surprised me because it appeared to come
out of nowhere however looking back over
the season it seems they connected over
their similar feelings about the loss of
Charlotte I hope you know that I'm here
for you you're not alone see that's just
said I never used to feel alone because
I always had the big guy I really miss
him I was just so mad so mad after
Charlotte I've been mad too but by the
end of the season Ella puts her crucifix
back on and Dan understands the
foolishness of going back to his old
shady ways as for Trixie well it was
nice to see her make up with Mays but I
wish we'd seen a lot more of her she's
such a good actress now on the screen
chemistry is so great with all the adult
actors where do you live here where are
you from
far away I came here for Lucifer keeps
commentary to yourself thing however I
think she may be a casualty of having a
shorter season now fingers crossed we
see more of her next time by the way if
you're curious about what Mays really
said when she spoke lil um to Linda tap
at the top of the screen to check out my
other Lucifer video
so how do you feel about the ending to
season 4 and do you have any predictions
or things you'd like to see in season 5
leave your thoughts in the comments
below
tapleft to watch another loose for video
with devilish details about the show or
tap write for another video you're sure
to like and if you enjoyed this comes up
and a share are hugely appreciated
thanks for watching and see you next
time you PK movie lovers